hi
everybody my name is kathy stennerson
and i
am an analytical science liaison with
milliport sigma
in north america and today i am going to
talk to you and show you how to do a
catcher's extraction and clean up
for hemp flour now this is just one way
to do this
for those of you out there that have to
do pesticide testing depending on your
matrix
and depending on what you're looking for
there are different approaches and you
have to find the one that works the best
for you
this is just one way that i'm going to
demonstrate today so catchers is an
acronym and it stands for quick
easy cheap effective rugged and
safe it's a an extraction that
was developed to replace a much more
labor intensive extraction that worked
with much more hazardous solvents
so there are four basic steps with
catchers
that we're going to use with the hemp
flour because hemp flour is a dry
material so our first step we're going
to hydrate it
and then in our next step we're going to
add solvent and do an extraction
then we're going to do a salting out
step
and then we're going to do a clean up
and i'll explain these in detail along
the way
so to get started i'm going to go over
and weigh out my hand flour
okay so the first step is to weigh out
our hemp flour that has been
we have hemp that's already been ground
up okay so that's already been done for
me
so i have i'm gonna weigh it right into
the tube i'm gonna do the extraction and
this is a 50 ml extraction tube for
catchers
now this this particular tube i like
because
inside the cap there's a ridge in there
a plastic ridge
and the reason that's good is because
when i seal it up
and i start doing my extraction i'm
going to be shaking this too
and this ridge prevents solvent and what
not from leaking out
so we're going to put our extraction
tube on the balance
and tear it and i'm going to be weighing
out one gram
of my ground temp
like i said different methods different
approaches but in this method that we're
doing we're just going to
use one gram of material right there
okay i'm at 1.02 so i would record 1.03
so i would record that weight that way i
can use it when i calculate my final
results
all right in the next step then our
catchers you've got to see the natural
to do an extraction but this is a dry
material
okay so we're going to need to hydrate
it with water first
so i'm going to add 10 ml of water to
this
and i have water that is generated by
it's just deionized water so from a
regular laboratory deionized water
system that's fine
and i'm going to add this is a five mil
pipette
i'm going to add two five mil aliquots
to this
put my lid on and shake it up to mix it
and then just let it sit for 60 minutes
to hydrate that sample
okay so now it's been about 60 minutes
our sample has been sitting with
with water on it and it's hydrated and
ready to extract
so the extraction itself is done with
acetonitrile
when you're working with produce this
extraction was originally developed for
produce
produce already has a lot of water in it
so you just basically
um smash it up homogenize it and
have this slurry you add your cedar
nitrile
do your extraction add your salts now
the salts then will
cause the now normally water and pseudo
nitrile immiscible
however when you add salt it dissolves
in the water layer
and it forces the acetonitrile and the
water to separate
so they're no longer miserable when you
have all that ionic content
in there and that's how you end up with
layers and the idea is is that your
pesticides are going to go into the
acetonitrile layer
which you're going to draw off and then
do analysis on
so because our hem is very dry
we need to add water to it there's no
there's not enough water naturally
incurred in there for us to get
phases like that so for the salting part
you have a couple choices for your salts
that you're going to add
after we do the extraction because we
did our hydration next we're going to
add a serum nitrile and shake it up
real well and then we're going to add
salt and shake it again
we can either add salts that are
considered non-buffered and it's
basically sodium chloride and magnesium
sulfate
or buffer buffered meaning that there's
different salts in there that and this
is better if you have ph sensitive
pesticides
non-buffered was the very first approach
developed just
the salts that are there to create those
layers
okay the buffered approach came later
when there were certain pesticides that
were
ph sensitive and they were breaking down
during the extraction
now as far as if you're going to do
buffer you have two choices there
you can either do an acetate buffered
extraction or a citrate buffer
extraction these two approaches were
developed by two different people
one of them here in the us and one over
in europe
they were developed and actually people
a lot of times will try
both to see which one they get better
recoveries with
one thing to note buffered versus
non-buffer
you will if you do buffered you will
pull out more background
than if you do non-buffered however if
you have ph sensitive pesticides this is
the way to go
but just be aware that is one downside
so you're gonna have to do
a cleanup that's maybe a little more
rigorous
so we're gonna go over to the hood now
and i'm gonna go ahead and do the
extraction part
all right so now i'm at my hood and i'm
going to be adding acetonitrile to
actually do the extraction of the hem
and whenever you're working with organic
solvent you always want to work under a
hood
so it's been sitting for 60 minutes you
can see it's it's nice and
nice and wet there so i'm going to add
10 mils of acetonitrile
i'm just using hplc grade acetonitrile
for this step
you can use um better grades if you find
that that is necessary although this for
for what i'm doing this is going to be
okay
so i'm adding 10 ml of my acetonitrile
closing my lid and i'm just going to
give it a quick shake now you see that
there's no layers there it's all i mean
the water and the acetonitrile
has just all mixed together so one way
for the shaking part to do our
extraction we can we can do this by hand
for a minute which is okay except if
you've got like a bunch of samples
you're going to be pretty tired at the
end of the day
a better approach is an automated shaker
so i'm going to show you an automated
shaker
so this is a benchtop automated shaker
and i'll be able to shake up to one two
three four five six seven samples at a
time if i had them
and i could shake much faster and for
longer and the advantage of that is that
you're going to get
better extraction efficiency for certain
things
okay and there's been studies that have
been done that have proven this so i'm
going to shake my sample at 2500 rpm for
10 minutes
so i'm going to put my foam down there
lower this down and start it up
so as you can see this is going to do a
lot better shaking than i could do
so we'll let that go for 10 minutes then
we'll be back
okay so we're done shaking now i'm going
to take my
hemp sample that's being extracted out
of here all right
you can see that it's still one layer
there's no
phases yet i don't have a seer nitrile
and water face so now i'm gonna do the
salting out step
so i'm gonna walk back over to the hood
and pick up my salts here i've got
i decided to use a citrate tube for this
like i said
a lot of labs will try the different
types of salts and see which one works
the best for them
so there's never one method fits all
okay so um
these are already pre-weighed out these
salts okay we've got
a variety of salts in here so i'm just
going to open this guy up
and didn't leak see that nice ridge
there kept it from leaking
and i'm going to add the salts now dump
them in
and shake for about a minute i could put
it back on the shaker
but you really don't need to for this
step the extraction part which just
happened that's where you really need
the shaker so all i'm doing now
is i'm just getting the salts in there
they're going to partially dissolve in
the water
so they're going to create a very high
ionic environment
that's going to drive if there were any
pesticides it's going to drive them
further into the acetonitrile layer and
then it's also going to cause those
phases that's the water and acetyl
nitrol to separate
and the acetonitrile will be on the top
so after we shake for about a minute you
can see this would get really tiring if
you had a lot of samples
we're going to centrifuge this to get
the layers to separate
it's much faster than just letting it
sit
and much more efficient
you guys spent about a minute
okay so i'm gonna stick this in the
centrifuge now now a lot of times it's
really common for your sample to warm up
when you add the salts and shake it okay
so that don't don't uh don't worry
that's not normal
so i'm going to put it in my centrifuge
now i got a balanced tube here
i'm going to centrifuge it 5000 rpm
for 10 minutes and then when we take it
out we'll see some nice layers
set our rpm up to 5000 and we'll
let it start
okay we'll see you in 10 minutes all
right so the
centrifuge is done now so i'm going to
take the uh
sample out
and that's what it looks like so on the
top the green layer is the acetonitrile
we have an interface layer we call that
of some of the hemp
flower material and the brown layer
underneath
is the water layer and then we have like
a little jelly kind of looking
bit at the bottom of the tube and that's
some undissolved salts
so now my next step is to take this top
layer off
and we're going to have to clean that
and you can imagine
it's pretty green so you don't want to
inject that
in an expensive gc triple quad or lc
triple quad
because it's going to get the instrument
dirty when you do a lot of samples over
time so our our goal is to to get that
green color out of there and clean it up
okay
so first let's draw the layer off here
and then i'm going to talk a little bit
about the different
options we're going to show for cleanup
so i'm under my hood again safety first
and i got myself a vial
i like to use glass for um a lot of
things but
um in this case i'm using it
so that you can see the color easily
so nice and green beautiful green color
for 10 mils you're usually gonna get
about
eight mils of acetonitrile back off when
you extract the tent
that's the general rule of thumb
all right so i'm just going to draw up
enough so we have enough to work with
for what we're doing
all right that should be enough
okay so that's what we got to work with
so next
part i'm going to talk a little bit
about clean up
all right so now that we've got that
beautiful green hemp extract we're going
to do the cleanup step
now there's there's different options
for doing this
for catchers the cleanup step
uses loose sorbents okay so there's
different clean absorbents you can use
and you may have seen them already
available packed in cartridges that you
pass your sample through
well in catchers the sorbents are loose
so the idea is that you take some of the
extract and you put it in a tube
that's got loose sorbet in it like this
shake it up the sorbent then retains the
interferences
you centrifuge this to drive the sorbent
down to the bottom of the tube and then
draw
off the supernatant which has now been
cleaned
there's different sorbents for doing
this and what we're going to look at
today
is we're going to look at three
different options our first option
is a mixture of c18
and psa that's this stuff here it's
white this white powder it's two things
mixed together
c18 is an 18 carbon chain
that's stuck onto a silica particle so
think of like the same kind of thing as
what's
packed inside of an hplc column some spe
cartridges
c18 will remove hydrophobic
interferences because the c18 chain is
very hydrophobic so it's going to retain
hydrophobic interferences
psa stands for primary secondary amine
and this material will remove acidic
interferences
so think fatty acids if you had any
sugars there because they have all these
hydroxyl groups on in their structure
it will retain those the second thing
we're going to look at
is we're going to look at this same
blend but
containing a carbon
g c b graphitized
carbon black gcb stands for graphitized
carbon black
this removes color in our case it's
going to remove
green color okay now
this is really good for removing color
the problem is
is it can sometimes remove some of the
things that we're looking for
some of the pesticides that maybe we're
targeting in this will retain on the
carbon
the same with with uh with the other
sorbents too so you have to be aware
that that if you're you're working with
say
an acidic pesticide you need to look for
an acidic pesticide
you want to avoid a mix that has this in
there because it's going to retain it
so graphitize carbon black so that's our
third mixture
our second mixture our third mixture is
a
custom is a sorbent blend that only mild
for sigma
offers and it's called sapel q
verde verde is spanish for green
and it contains three different things
something called z-sep plus it contains
our friend the primary secondary amine a
little bit of that
and it contains a carbon okay but it's
not this quite the same as
traditional graphitized carbon black
i'll explain
now first z sub plus this is a
a sorbent that's exclusive to us it's a
zirconia
and c18 coated silica
zirconia has some special properties for
removing fatty interferences and it can
also remove
some color envy carb y
will help remove the green but it's not
as strong
as graphitized carbon black so it won't
retain other things that we want to see
quite as strongly let me demonstrate
[Music]
this is graphitized carbon black okay
graphitized carbon exists as sheets
so chlorophyll which gives the green
color to our health
this is chlorophyll chlorophyll is what
we call a planar molecule
it's flat so what happens is when it
interacts with the carbon it goes
in between the sheets and it gets
retained
this is good we want this the problem is
if we're looking for a pesticide like
hexachlorobenzene
it too is flat or planar so it
can get retained by the carbon in the
same way that's the downside of this
graphitized carbon black
this nd carb y that's in the verde mix
is graphitized but its surface area
is much smaller it's not as strong
so it's going to be able to retain
larger
planar molecules like our chlorophyll
but it will not as strongly retain the
small
guys like our hexachlorobenzene they're
going to be able to escape
a lot easier okay so that's the reason
for the verde mixture so i want to see
basically what my extract looks like
when i use it versus the traditional psa
c18 graphitized carbon black
all right so now we're going to do that
cleanup step with those three options i
just talked about
this is our psa c18 it's white because
if both of those materials are white in
color
this is that same mixture but with the
graphitized carbon black blended in
there so you can see that it's it's
black
this is the verde mixture that has that
lower surface area carbon
and then the z sub plus and then psa so
it's a little more
it's a little less dark in color but you
can still see the carbon in there
so um these tubes i'm going to put
extract directly in them with the loose
sorbents and then i'm going to shake
the tubes for about a minute
you want one mill of extract
these are two mil size you can get these
in bigger size too if you need to clean
more extract
so one mill
and i'm going to put a little bit here
so we have we can do a little color
comparison when we're done we're going
to take the extracts out put them in
these nice clear test tubes so that we
can see
how they look all right so
cap these guys up
and after i shake these for a minute i'm
going to put them in a centrifuge
to get the sorbents down to the bottom
of the tube so we can take off the
sample the supernatants
shake for about a minute these won't
heat up on you like the other
extraction tooth did and this is another
one where you could use the automated
shaker if you have a lot of samples
because it'll just save you from getting
tired out
okay i'm going to kind of walk over to
the shaker as i'm shaking just to save a
little bit of time here
see it's kind of a dreary day today for
us
all right so i got a different
centrifuge that will handle
these little tubes
so we really can't see what's happening
in there yet because the carbon's
all up and up with the sample mixed in
there right now so we really have to
centrifuge to get a good look at the
at the extract to see what it looks like
[Music]
i
and we're going to do 5000 rpm for about
we'll do five minutes that should be
plenty of time
all right so we'll see in five minutes
all right and we're back centrifuge is
done
and i'm going to take those cleaned
extracts out of there
take a look at them
all right so that's the psa c18 gcb
when we pull it out you'll see better
but it uh green is pretty much gone
out of that so we're going to pull out
the extracts and put them in these tubes
it'll be a little easier to see
that's our balance too this is the psac
18.
and um it's a little lighter in color
but it's still pretty green
looks to me but we'd expect that right
because
there's no carbon in there and then
there's our verde
now the verde it pulled out some green
but not as much as the uh
the graphitized carbon black did so now
i'm going to take these over to the hood
and draw the supernatant off and put
them in these test tubes
all right so now i'm going to take the
uh cleaned
extract off of the sorbent now that we
have spun these down
all right you got to do this kind of
carefully because
you don't want to disrupt the sorbent
bed
so here is my verde cleaned extract now
i'm going to put some in this test tube
so that you can see the color all right
and then i'm going to deposit a little
bit in my auto sampler valve here
and i'm going to explain about auto
sampler vials a little bit later
all right so that's good enough for that
one
next is our pace psa
c18 graphitized carbon black
clean sample
that's pretty clear
a little bit i have a sample around here
i'm just saving steps that way i'd also
get two sets of pipettes dirty
okay and then the last one i've got is
just psac 18
cleaned
all right so now let's take a look at
the collar oops missed my waist bucket
all right so we got no cleanup
and this is cleaned with the verde so
it's now kind of yellow
so the verde took out quite a bit of the
chlorophyll
and it's still but still a little bit
yellow now
comparatively
here is the the graphitized carbon black
psa c18 you see it's almost completely
clear
but remember the downside remember what
i showed you with those
of those cutouts of the molecules it
takes out the chlorophyll but it's also
going to
more much more strongly retain planar
molecules that might be some of the
pesticides that you're targeting
now the last cleanup was our
psa c18 and that didn't have any carbon
in it
so it it's it's a little
it's a little green okay it took out
some color but it's still kind of green
so if you were to do a color scale this
is the clearest
this is probably the second and then
that's the third and of course no
cleanup it's still very green
so uh there's always a downside to
everything you just gotta choose what
works best for you
now i did put a little bit in some auto
sampler vials over here
for getting ready for the instrument
after this step
there's depending on what you're doing
there's different approaches now some
people take this extract
and they will do a dilution into
something that's more compatible with
their mobile phase for lcms
for injection for a gc some people will
do a solvent exchange or they'll just
inject it directly it just depends on
like i said what you're looking for what
you're doing
the vials themselves these are pretty
typical auto sampler vials
two mil now amber and clear you have a
choice of amber and clear
if you're worried about photo
degradation
of some of the pesticides of interest
i recommend you go with amber if you're
not sure
i recommend you go with amber okay just
to play to be on the safe side
if you don't have a lot of volume to
work with there's these
vials available with little inserts in
them like i have here so i don't need to
put very much
extract in there the auto sample will be
able to pick it up just fine
and these particular vials
i like to use for pesticides they're
called
low absorption so these are certified
for mass spec use they've been tested
for cleanliness
and also the glass has it's
it's a high purity glass so there's less
chance that you'll have absorption of
your
analytes to the surface of the glass or
contamination
from metals as for the caps the caps are
also ultra clean that come with these
now for cap style if you're going to be
doing
hplc i recommend we like to use
caps with slits in the septum see these
are
these are um caps with teflon lined
septa in there
now this one has you probably can't
really see it very well but there's a
little slit
that goes all the way through it's
closed right now but that for hplc it
allows the auto sampler
to get down through the septic easier
less chance of
coring and plugging for gc i use a solid
septa because that's a very sharp needle
that's puncturing that septum
so then you would just simply do
whatever step that if you're going to
directly do a direct injection of the
extract you just cap these up and you're
ready to go
or if you have another step after this
you just take your extract and go ahead
with your solvent exchange revolution
so that's what i got for you today and
happy catchers everybody
hi my name is jeff rule i'm a principal
scientist here at millipore sigma
at our bellefonte pennsylvania location
so i'm happy
to talk with you today in this training
session a little bit about how to
perform a t-infusion experiment
to study and characterize matrix
suppression effects that we often see
in electrospray ionization and then i'd
also like to
show you how we can make use of stable
isotope labeled internal standards
to correct for these suppression effects
so we're going to start off describing
this t infusion experiment
you can use a stainless steel t as as
i've got here or a peak t
doesn't matter too much in general
which type you use but you can see then
that i've got this t
coupled to our ionization source
one port is connected to the effluent
coming from our hplc column
over here and then the third port
is connected to our syringe and so here
i have a
a one milliliter syringe that i'm going
to fill
with a solution of my pesticides
in this case i have a solution of
approximately 200 picograms per
milliliter
of my pesticides just in pure solvent
and i'm going to connect that
to the third port of these of the
t
now in this case we actually have
a syringe pump that's built into the
mass spectrometer
in some cases you may not have that but
you can purchase standalone syringe
pumps
to perform the same experiment
so now we've got everything connected we
can start the
flow of the syringe pump that's
controlled through the software it would
typically be set at about 10 microliters
per minute
and we run a sample of
our blank matrix extract on our hplc
system so we we use the autosampler and
the same
gradient that we plan to use for our
real analytical work
we run we inject that sample and the
t-infusion experiment will then show us
where the suppression effects occur
through the chromatographic run so
you'll see that
more in the following slides
here again is a depiction of the t
infusion experiment
the reason we do this is so that we can
see how our matrix
a blank matrix that we take through the
extraction
procedure we plan on using how it will
affect the signal intensity of
our analytes of interest in this case
pesticides
so we take a hemp or cannabis extract we
inject it onto the lc
column it ideally would be a
clean sample that does not have any
pesticides in it
and while we're infusing the pesticides
from the syringe pump
we can then use the mass spectrometer to
show us where
the signal intensity declines as a
result
of introducing our extract onto the hplc
column
this figure shows the results of the tea
infusion experiment
after injecting a hemp extract onto
my lc system and column
so the color traces show the signal
intensity of a mixture of different
pesticides
the overlaid chromatogram shows where
the cannabinoids eluded off of the
column
this was done in a separate experiment
but you can see in this figure how
the elution of the cannabinoids off the
hplc column
coincides with suppression of the the
pesticide signal intensity
so the t infusion experiment can be very
helpful in understanding where matrix
interferences come off depending on the
matrix that we're looking at
so here we can see a variety of
different candies that
are expected to be quite similar but
yet you can see they have different
colorants and likely
flavorings possibly other additives
in each of these different candies so by
preparing extracts of these and
performing the tea infusion experiment
we can see if it's necessary to make
adjustments to our chromatography
or sample cleanup for these different
matrices
so i'd like to take this a step further
in
describing how we might expect these
different candies
with the different additives to
potentially impact our our quantitative
efforts
with these two simulated illustrations
here
so on the left we have a situation
where our t-infusion experiment shows
relatively constant
level of suppression and if that occurs
across the retention time
of our analog internal standard and our
analyte
then we may get a true reflection of the
ratio of these two components and get
accurate quantitation however on the
right
we have possibly some different
colorants
that cause this increasing signal
suppression
as our analyte comes off and so
the degree of suppression is different
between the analyte and the internal
standard
it skews the ratio of the two
and therefore will create an erroneous
quantitation or possibly excessive
deviation
in our quantitation in this case
so one possible scenario is shown here
where we migrate to having a perfectly
colluding
isotopically labeled internal standard
now both the internal standard and the
analyte see
exactly the same degree of suppression
so their ratio
is not skewed in any way we can still
get
accurate quantitation okay so you've
just seen how a stable isotope labeled
compound can negate the effects
of suppression that we often see in
electrospray ionization
so uh i just wanted to touch upon what
isotope labeling is in case it's been a
while since you've taken
chemistry but basically you know that
we've got the
nucleus of the atom is comprised in
general
of protons and neutrons and then in
addition we have electrons
somewhere orbiting around the nucleus of
the atom
so when we have a heavy isotope or a
stable isotope
we actually simply have an additional
neutron
in the nucleus of the atom and so if we
have one additional neutron
then our mass let's say we're thinking
of
carbon a normal carbon atom or the most
abundant
form of carbon is carbon-12 it has six
protons and six
neutrons if we add one additional
neutron
then we end up with carbon 13.
and this is a stable isotope it occurs
naturally
uh in all carbon in approximately one
percent
and so what our chemists do is to purify
carbon 13 for example possibly
a deuterium you can also get deuterium
or nitrogen 15 labeling
but we get this purified heavy isotope
isotopic material and then our chemists
synthesize
the compounds of interest using the
heavy material
and because it's heavier then and we're
doing mass spectrometry
we can distinguish our stable isotope
labeled internal standard
from the native or unlabeled analyte
so now let's take a look at
a few other situations that you may
observe
when you're doing your method
development or validation
and how it pertains to the use of
stable isotope labeled internal
standards
so we're talking about suppression i
want to just point out
another type of suppression something
that i call self-suppression
that's commonly seen in atmospheric
pressure ionization
and this is simply a result of getting
reduced ionization efficiency as we go
up in analyte concentration
as you would when you're creating a
calibration curve
so in the absence of a good internal
standard
our signal intensity will begin to
decline
as the concentration goes up and this
can cause
non-linear calibration curves
this points out though why isotopically
labeled
or perfectly coaluting internal
standards are so valuable
if we have such an internal standard
it will come off at the same time in our
chromatographic run and therefore see
the exact same degree of suppression for
self-suppression could be matrix
suppression
no matter what the cause the extent of
the suppression will be the same
for both the analyte and the internal
standard and we can therefore get
nice linear calibration curves
this figure illustrates another type of
suppression but in this case from
coeluting analytes as we might have in
the case of a calibration
standard so what i've done here is to
create
a plot in which i've
got peak areas of hexathiazox when
injected by itself
and then also in combination with two
other analytes that coelute with the
hexythiazokes these were phenpyroxamate
and detoxazole
you can see that when the three
are combined in solution and then
injected on the lc system
there's an average of 13 percent
suppression of the hexathiazok's peak
area
in comparison with a situation where the
hexathiazox is by itself
so this could conceivably cause a bias
in your quantitation due to the fact
that your calibration standards
would likely have more than one
coaluting pesticide
in the mixture
the next two figures then summarize the
benefits of having isotopically labeled
internal standard as we go through the
simple preparation the extraction in the
lc msms analysis
so in this figure let's imagine that
we've got an analog internal standard
one that does not elude at the same time
as our analyte
we start off by putting the internal
standard
in at a one-to-one ratio with the
analyte
as we go through the extraction
procedure we
may find that we have variable recovery
of the analyte and the internal standard
so that our ratio is no longer at one to
one
as we go into the ionization source for
the mass spectrometry
we can get variable suppression effects
as i've shown earlier with the candies
so for example
one or the other of the two compounds
will
possibly differ in terms of their signal
intensity
this also tends to throw off the ratio
that we measure in the mass spectrometer
and so will cause
poor accuracy when we do the
quantitation
with a stable isotope labeled internal
standard on the other hand
or a sil is we add at a one-to-one ratio
with our analyte
and because the compound the two
compounds
are almost identical in terms of
their physical chemical structure the
only thing that differs is their mass
they behave virtually identically
in going through the sample preparation
extraction procedure
and so even though we may have something
like 50 percent loss
in the extraction process as well as
having
a suppression effect at the ionization
source the ratio of the two will remain
the same
and because we use this ratio for a
quantitation
the accuracy can remain very good
okay so hopefully you'll find some of
these ideas suggestions
and experiments useful when you're doing
your own research
i can definitely recommend the use of
stable isotope labeled internal
standards and the t
suppression experiment in order to
understand where
matrix suppression effects are occurring
they may help you adjust your
chromatography or they may suggest
that you adjust your chromatography or
perhaps
go to a slightly modified sample cleanup
in order to get cleaner sample extracts
and so in this way with these
experiments
and good internal standards you can get
the best
quantitation in your sample analysis
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your interest and
don't hesitate to contact myself or
any other members of our team if you
would like to
consult with us more or talk about your
own
method development applications
welcome to kenner lab my name is rafael
in this talk i'll be sharing some tips
and tricks for preparing instrument
calibration standards
for pesticides analysis i hope that you
find this information informative
and with these tips and tricks you can
continue to advance your laboratory
productivity by reducing unnecessary
downtime
our robust portfolio developed by
analytical chemists
for analytical chemists covers a broad
range of analytical solutions and every
product undergoes meticulous quality
control
to maintain the integrity of your
testing protocols we provide
chromatographic solvents columns and
supplies
certified reference materials and
reagents to ensure you always obtain
consistent results in your laboratory
analysis
let's go over the workflow for the
analysis of pesticides in cannabis
first we obtain legal hemp containing
less than 0.3 percent thc
based on the cla matrix match
calibration standards were prepared and
split into two aliquots
a combination of lcms ms and gcm sms was
used to evaluate
66 california regulated pesticides a
complete customer
solution or workflow utilizing
prospective reagents
and instrument consumables was generated
the results shown here
are an excerpt of an upcoming
application note for the analysis of
pesticides in cannabis flower
to meet the color the current california
regulations
current california requirements for
pesticides in cannabis
indicate the following there are 21
category 1 pesticides
listed for which there is no allowable
level methods must demonstrate the limit
of detection for these compounds and all
limits of detections
must be at least 0.1 micrograms
per gram or lower for inhalable cannabis
goods any detectable amount of these
pesticides
results in the product failing there are
category 2 pesticides for which there
are prescribed action levels
action levels vary by pesticides and are
based on whether the product
is an inhalable cannabis good or other
product form
these compounds must be below the action
level to result in an acceptable or
passing product
we took a look at this list and we
checked it twice and realized that they
were
going to we're going to need dual
instrument approach for this particular
analysis
those analytes in bold are not amenable
to electrospray
lcm sms
triple quadruple mass spectrometers are
designed for targeted analysis
and provide the maximum sensitivity when
performing analysis
in complex matrices these instruments
have the capabilities of analyzing parts
protruding concentrations
which is analyte and matrix dependent
typically
parts per million concentrations and
above can
often times saturate the detector or
cause carryover from injection to
injection
for this reasons sample preparation is
extremely important
these factors must be taken into effect
when analyzing cannabis as it contains
targeted components or analytes
at the part per billion level in this
case for pesticides
components in the parts per million
level such as
terpenes and other components at the
percent level such as cannabinoids
among other components not just targeted
at this particular time
there are many different possible ways
to get analytes extracted prior to
analysis
in terms of sample preparation
techniques available to us
as analytical chemists you can utilize
spme or solid phase microextraction
solid liquid extraction catchers which
is an acronym from
quick easy cheap effective rugged and
safe there's pros and cons to this
techniques
when applied to cannabis flower or solid
phase extraction
diluting shoot which is not a viable
option for this particular matrix
the use of proper valves is extremely
important as some pesticides photo
degrade
and also due to the large concentration
analyte absorption
can occur in vials without the activated
surfaces
which leads to loss of analytes and
irreproducible responses
therefore mass spec certified low
absorption amber vials are essential
to the analysis of pesticides usually
utilizing any analytical technique
a more important important question
becomes how do we get what we want
inside the vial
while at the same time minimizing the
components and matrix
that we do not want our selected method
of sample preparation was based on how
do we maximize analyte recovery
what would maximize instrument uptime
what is feasible
and what customers were already doing in
the marketplace
or were willing to try
let's go over the sample preparation
steps
one gram of dried and ground cannabis
sample
was transferred into a 50 ml
polypropylene centrifuge
tube today to this
ceramic homogenization beads were added
in addition to 15 mils of lcms grade
acetonitrile
and it was capped the tube was shaking
for 5 to 10 minutes on a vertical shaker
at high speed
prepare a tube rack with discovery c18
500mg spe cartridges
six mil and 50 mil
centrifuge tubes for collection
add supernatant from discovery c18 spe
cartridge and less pad
pass through by gravity add
five mils of additional acetonitrile to
2a
and shake for three to five minutes at
high speeds
transfer supernatant to spe cartridge
repeat with an additional five mils of
acn and again
pass through the spe cartridge bring
final volume of the centrifuge tube to
25 mils with acn
this gives us a 25x dilution factors
for samples let's take a look at the gcm
sms instrument conditions
please note that the injection mode is a
pressure and temperature program solvent
vent injection
this was coupled with a sandwich
injection of sample with analyte
protectants
we'll discuss analyte protectants in
greater details in the next few slides
a supelco slb-5ms column provided low
chromatographic bleed
at the elevated gc temperatures the
sandwich injection technique is very
simple to set up
with most auto samplers and provides
many benefits in introducing matrix
internal standards
or in this case analyte protecting
solutions as a co-injection
here the listed acquisition parameters
for gcm sms amenable pesticides
in the california list typically we use
two mrm transitions per analyte
one for quantitation and the other mrm
transition as a qualifier
however sometimes lights use a third and
possibly fourth mrn transitions
in case there are unexpected matrix
interferences
and why not it's free to acquire the
third
or fourth mrm i say that with a caveat
however
there's no such thing as a free lunch
it's kind of free however you pay for it
in terms of dwell time which may affect
your sensitivity and reproducibility
if your method is not fully optimized
for example
you may not get enough data points
across the chromatographic peaks
but that's the conversation for another
similar topic perhaps at a later time
i promise we'll get back to analyte
protecting solutions
here we can clearly see the benefits of
utilizing analyte protectants
in gcm sms analysis of pesticides
on the left we see five injections of a
particular analyte
without the use of analyte protectants
and on the right
we see how the results significantly
improved
with their use analytic protectants
are used to minimize minimize active
sites in the gc
inlet and sample path and to ensure
reproducible and consistent results
when analyzing pesticides at low levels
analyte protectants are only designed
for gcms analysis
not for lc they do not function in lcms
analysis
analyte protectants with with hydroxyl
groups for example sugars and sugar
derivatives
have shown to be especially effective
since they can block active sites in the
gc system
via hydrogen bonds when using analyte
protectants
significantly lower peaks
significantly narrower peaks can be
obtained from many analytes
thus the chromatographic separation is
improved
lower detection limits are achieved and
the determination of the peak area is
simplified
and more precise essentially your
analytes are sugar-coated
a key takeaway message here is that
analyte protectants are important
and required for the analysis of low
levels of pesticides in any matrix
not just cannabis
response is dependent on initial analyte
concentration
if you're analyzing ppm or above levels
of pesticides the effective minimal at
around
five percent however if you're working
at low concentrations parts per billion
concentrations nanograms per ml
or especially parts per trillion
picograms per
ml the effects are more pronounced for
example
as illustrated in this picture you may
start with a
100 of analytes and end up with 10
you may have possible analyte
interactions which
with active sites in the sample vials
syringe barrel
inlet liner column inlet analytical
column
mass spectrometer ionization source all
these sites
prior to the analytes reaching the
instrument detector
in this example we see
pentachloronitrobenzene or pcnb
which is a problematic electrospray
electrospray ionization lcm sms compound
which is easily ionized and analyzed via
gcm sms
the minimum action level for
pentrochloronitrobenzene
is 100 ppb in cannabis flower which
corresponds
to a four ppb nanograms per ml
in bio concentration excellent
reproducibility and linear range are
shown here
with the use of analyte protectants
these isomer peaks for cyfluthrin 1 and
are summed and quantitated as one please
note that even though these peaks are
not chromatographically
separated they can still be quantitated
and the results are reproducible
the minimum action level for cyfluthrin
is three
micrograms per gram or three ppm in
flour
which corresponds to 120 nanograms per
ml
or 120 ppb in vial based on the 25x
dilution
during sample and standard preparation
note here the excellent linearity and
reproducibility in matrix match
standards
for these sets of isomers again using
analyte protectants
this total ion chromatogram illustrates
the various components typically found
in cannabis flowers terpenes
cannabinoids
and other flavonoids note that the
height
amount of cbd compared to other
components in this chromatogram
here we see a total ion chromatogram of
a 200 ppb
matrix match standard with analyte
protectants in this case the high cbd
concentration did
not impact the quantitation of the
analytes then coeluted in the same
chromatographic region
here are the tabling that results for
the gcms ms amenable pesticides in the
california list
note the excellent reproducibility
recovery and sensitivity
as well as linearity reach for each
individual analyte
and here's the tabular results for all
pesticides in the california lists
essentially 60 analyzed by lcm sms 36 by
gcm sms
and 31 by both techniques
let's take a look on how to perform a
matrix enhancements
suppression and recovery evaluation for
this
a set of calibration standards is
prepared in pure acetonitrile
and used to generate an ideal
calibration curve
against which suppression enhancement
and extraction recovery studies can be
performed
this is curve b to evaluate suppression
and enhancement effects a set of
calibrators is prepared
from a post-extraction sample for this
preparation
a blank or control matrix of
analyte-free
cannabis is taken through the sample
preparation procedure
before adding the pesticide working
solution
comparison of the post extract
regression
calibration curve with the regression
performed in pure acetonitrile
allows evaluation of either suppression
or enhancement effects
note that suppression or enhancements
effects can occur with both gcms and
lcms
instrumentation although the costs
are somewhat different studies of these
effects
can provide insights into possible
remedies that may be used to improve
assay performance to evaluate extraction
recovery
a set of plant calibration standards is
prepared
so this set of standards is spiked with
working solution
and then taken through the sample
preparation procedure
comparison of these calibrators with
those prepared from the post extraction
set allows evaluation of extraction
recovery
or losses that occur during the
extraction procedure
in conclusion the cannabis industry is
growing and evolving rapidly in the u.s
while testing quality control and
enforcement tries to keep place
our workflows are positioned to assist
customers with
anticipated worth growth and testing
a unified sample preparation technique
for pesticide residue provides customers
with an effective way
to easily reach the regulatory limits
ensuring that analyte protectants are
used
for gcms analysis of pesticides in
cannabis
and cannabis related products
thank you so much if you have any
questions
i'll be glad to answer them have a great
day and enjoy ken lab
you